Denise the owner of a small clothing
boutique is asking for the community's
help to find the person who broke into
their store happen early in the morning
last week and she says she is out
thousands of dollars Sasha Loftus spoke
with her tonight Sasha joining us live
near Sahara and Eastern now with more
Brian this is what the front of that
that's like now you can see by
e the Toronto tells me this is her
livelihood and she just wants to find
who did this
she came and she hid it from the bottom
anacelli Garcia recreates the moment a
burglar broke into her East Valley store
she even took the mannequin this was the
scene last Tuesday at XOXO boutique near
Sahara and Eastern after Garcia says
this person shattered the front door
with a pair of pliers and stole clothing
jewelry and cash it's just me so it's
really hard that you know everything I
worked for is gone in all she's out
about eight thousand dollars a huge blow
especially since the business is only
two years old financially it's a big hit
because I I feel like a lot of people
think that when you have a business you
have money but it's not necessarily like
that you have cash flow but you don't
really have money like that and
emotionally it's even harder to bounce
back as police continue to search for
suspect you don't really want to like
come back because for what right someone
else is going to come and and take that
that's why Garcia hopes anyone who may
have seen anything comes forward so she
can start to recover from something so
unexpected you're struggling just like
everyone else and keep doing the work
she loves I work really hard like this
is all I have
and Anna Sally tells me she was
switching insurance companies when this
burglary happened so she had to pay a
lot of this out of pocket again that
eight thousand dollars there is a
GoFundMe up right now if you'd like to
help out reporting live tonight Sasha
Loftus 8 News Now